In fact, it's been shown that
if you increase the supply of
primary care physicians by just 1 for
every 10,000 people, there's
a significant increase in quality, and
a significant decrease in the cost
of Medicare, which you may remember,
takes care of older people who are more
likely to have chronic disease.
Conversely, if there's a similar
decrease in the availability of primary
care physicians, there's an almost
equal decrease in quality.
And a nearly equal increase
in the cost of Medicare.
You may be asking why?
Well, one of the major reasons
is that specialists charge more.
And they do far more tests and
procedures.
Moreover, how do they
coordinate their care?
How does each of these specialists, and
remember Marla may not even see
the same cardiologist every time she
visits that office,
know what all of the others are doing.
In particular, how do each of these
specialists know what medications
all of the others have prescribed?
This is important, because the same
research that showed Marla
will likely see 14 providers each year,
also showed she would likely fill
50 prescriptions that same year.